des rues jonchées de cadavres de civils
et des fausses communes
ces images avaient choqué le monde
entier et sont devenus pour beaucoup le
symbole des exactions russes en Ukraine
c'était il y a un an alors que l'armée
russe se retirait de bout de chat du
nord de Kiev après un mois d'occupation
dans cette ville qui comptait 37000
habitants avant la guerre le traumatisme
est toujours présent
ils ont tué mon gendre
il avait 47 ans 47 ans ils ont tué son
gendre et blessé son petit-fils
pouvez-vous imaginer
après le choc les Ukrainiens ont enterré
leurs morts devant les caméras du monde
entier
plusieurs mémoriaux ont été construits
pour ne pas oublier ce que beaucoup
dénoncent comme des crimes de guerre
il faut avoir le cœur bien accroché quel
que soit le monument que l'on regarde
ils étaient tous si jeunes si beaux
beaucoup de petits enfants se retrouvent
orphelins vous savez les gens veulent
juste vivre
aujourd'hui
Mucha se reconstruit tant bien que mal
pour essayer de clore ce douloureux au
chapitre on ne peut pas vraiment parler
de stabilisé cependant il y a ce désir
de se libérer de tout ce qui pourrait
rappeler le séjour des Russes ici ce
désir est dans le cœur l'âme et l'esprit
de chaque habitant de bout de chat c'est
pourquoi la ville c'est aujourd'hui
transformée en fourmilière pour amorcer
la reconstruction
des enquêtes internationales sont en
cours abouchaï dans le reste de
l'Ukraine afin de pouvoir juger les
responsables de ces massacres pour crime
de guerre ou génocide